welcome everybody we are we're getting
close very very close to the election
and um we predicted this timing could
happen
you don't have to be a master of
statistics or mathematics
to look at the coronavirus numbers and
understand that
we could be easily heading towards a
hundred thousand cases a day
within several weeks and when dr fauci
said it months ago when fauci said if we
don't do x
y and z we could be looking at one
hundred thousand
american coronavirus cases per day in
the fall
some people said he sounded crazy some
people said it made no sense some people
said oh
lockdown fouch you wants everything
closed forever
but indeed when you look at the numbers
it appears that we are going in a
direction
where part of the country is
pretending as though the pandemic is
over they're behaving as though
it's over but we are
set seeing new record numbers going back
several months in terms of cases
of course you have people saying well
cases are up but deaths aren't up
um and that is true sort of so far
although if you look at the seven day
average we now are
seeing an uptick in the number of deaths
so let's sort of look at everything from
the beginning
reset the pandemic so we can all get on
the same page
what i am going to put on the screen for
you here and i will describe it if
you're just listening
is a chart of us cases per day dating
all the way back to february
and then the blue line that you see
that's the seven day moving average
which shows
us the general week to week direction of
cases are they generally going up or
down
so you'll see that in mid-april we
peaked with about 32 000 cases a day
health measures were able to reduce that
down to about 20 000 cases a day in late
may
but then things started opening up and
dr fauci said you know we're not really
at the place where we can do
this we're only down to 20 000 cases a
day we need to be down at least to 10
000 a day with at least a million tests
a day to reopen
people didn't listen so we got another
spike and we went back up not to 32 000
cases a day
but all the way up to 70 000 cases a day
in mid-july
and then again with people being mostly
outdoors and lots of places taking more
serious measures
we were able to get back down to 35 000
cases a day
in early september so the first time
after a spike we got down to 20k the
next bike
was bigger and we only got down to 35k
and then we reopened more stuff movie
theaters casinos
and now in the last few days we've had
some of the
worst days including 72 000 cases in one
day
on friday and when you look at the trend
line now
you see that we are headed up and
potentially to 100
000 cases in a single day within a few
weeks now there are folks who are going
to say but but but but david deaths
aren't going up
deaths lag cases at by at least two to
three weeks
we now are better at treating this and
better at keeping people alive longer
so it would extend that lag time
even a little bit more but if you look
at the trend line on deaths
you will see that after a seven week
decline in the death trend line
it leveled out in early september and in
the last few days there's a small
but it is there blip upwards on deaths
and the expectation is that it will
continue to climb now i am the first to
admit
that there is some good news here which
is that we are better at treating this
now than we were six months ago
i expect that given x number of cases
today
versus x number of cases six months ago
fewer people would die today now in part
that's because younger people on average
are getting the disease right now
in part it's because you have very few
if any hospitals overwhelmed
right now and in part it's because we
have better treatment protocol and
some medications that are helping some
of the sickest patients
as soon as hospitals get overwhelmed if
it happens which they might as we enter
flu season
that could change and you could see the
rate of death go
up as well hopefully it won't now
similar things are happening in other
countries you remember
italy was one of the early hot spots
brutally hit
they got it under control they have now
had their worst week in the entire
pandemic in terms of cases in the last
week they had a record
almost 12 000 cases yesterday so
italy is spiking one other example
france which had it very much under
control
also with record spikes over the last 10
days much worse than what they had in
march and april and remember
italy and europe in general have not yet
had a second spike if you look at our
numbers
we had the april spike and the july
spike and now
we're seeing spike number three italy
france
european countries avoided that second
spike all summer
we may be heading to something
unconscionably worse
than what europe is heading towards and
meanwhile
donald trump continues to hold huge
rallies so we'll talk on the bonus show
later this week about what fall and
winter might look like
individually i've been reading some
medical recommendations about
thanksgiving and
and sort of dealing with some realities
there let me know what you are planning
for whether you're in the united states
or not
for the next four months essentially and
we'll discuss that on an upcoming bonus
show